>>>DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome, everyone, to active
inference lab institute. This is our
quarterly roundtable update number four
in 2022. It's December 14,
2022, and we're recording and then
instantly premiering this video due to
some tech difficulties. Welcome to
the active inference institute. We're a
participatory online institute that is
communicating, learning, and practicing
applied active inference. This is a
recorded and an archived Livestream, so
please provide us with feedback so we
can improve our work. All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome, and we'll
follow a video etiquette for
livestreams. All right, today in
the quarterly roundtable, we're going to
have three gain sections. We're going to
give some updates, ant the institute
scale, then talk about developments in
education and research, and finally
discuss a little bit active Inference
Institute in 2023. However, first,
those who are here, let's go around and
say hello. And if you would like one
memory or special part of this year or
just something you'll kind of take with
you going forward in 2023,
whoever wants to go first, just go for it.
>>>DAVID DOUGLASS: I'm Dave Douglass.
I was really pleased to get
praise from Professor Mark Souls,
a creator of a couple of different major
waves in contemporary psychoanalysis
and neuroscience, telling us it's going
to be a massive contribution, that we
are not only recording our in depth
discussion and presentation with him,
but publishing the transcript,
which is what I was hoping to hear every
time we inconvenienced ourselves and
stayed up late to get things out there
that we're perceived as having an
impact. Awesome.
That's great to hear.
>>>IVAN METELKIN: This quarter we finished one
another intensifying system, thinking it
is not quite related to the active
coherence theory activity,
but in a way it helps our
participants to communicate with each
other and move forward our
internal projects and their own
projects.
>>>BLEU KNIGHT: Cool. So I think for
me this year was probably the funnest
part, was the quantum stream.
I really enjoyed that a lot, and I
think that releasing the video
transcript for that will be great and
hopefully impactful. And I'm looking
forward to doing more quantum
information related type of work in
the future. And I think that was
probably the funnest memory for me.
>>>ALEX VYATKIN: I think interested was on organizational
aspects and transformation and
possibly related to it in
other aspects written that institute
structure. It's a good opportunity
for next year.
All right, thank you. Let's jump
right in and just raise your hands
whenever you want to address something.
And on we go.
Well, there's so many ways to COVID what
happened in the previous years, but this
image meme partially suffices.
So on the left side, we have the active
inference lab. AIL. And on the right
side we have us today, which is the
Active Inference Institute AI heading
into 2023. And we were active coherence
Lab lab from the first days of 2021
till the middle of 2022 for about 18
months. And since the middle of 2022,
we've been transforming on multiple
levels into the Active Inference
Institute. So, some baseball card
statistics ActInf Lab born 2020
AI born in the middle of 22 by
the end of 2021 we had 133 live streams.
We added about 85 or 84 more in
2022. Back in 2021,
the Active Inference ontology was just a
terms list. Today it includes
definitions, translations into many
languages and examples. In 2021,
the Active Inference textbook did not
exist. Yet today we're continuously
delivering interactive learning groups
and building an epistemic niche. In
2021, the Active Inference Journal
existed only for special events as a
proof of principle. And today, which
we'll discuss later, we're rapidly
transcribing, translating augmenting and
versioning transcripts and
in the active block, for instance
project in 2021 it was just a dream
within a dream. And today we're actually
implementing active inference in Cadcad
and there's other rows that could have
been added, but just a little summary
that brings us into our opening section
on updates at the organizational scale.
So, first related to the formal changes
and updates at the Institute, we would
like to welcome and appreciate our
inaugural cohort of the Board of
Directors, which began their work in
November 2022 that's John Klippenger,
Raphael Kaufman, Daniel Friedman, Dean
Tickles, Bleu Knight and Mike Smith.
The Board of Directors has had their
first meeting and over the about next
month or so, the Board of Directors will
be selecting officers. So we are
actively seeking self inclination and
suggestions for those who would like to
serve in an officer position president,
vice president, secretary, Treasurer,
especially with experience in
governance, financial, nonprofit and
education. So just signal interest in a
position or more generally and we will
be able to find a way for you to
contribute as soon as you're ready to
in the right way. And we're going to be
taking some steps as a nonprofit and as
an organization, for example, towards
tax exempt 501 status,
developing partnerships with other
distinctions and building our grants
program. Anyone ant to add anything
here.
The installment of the Board of
Directors also allows us to take
a look back on our Scientific Advisory
Board and those who served in 2022. So
Bradley Alicia john Boyk matt Brown John
Clippinger Scott David Jeff Emmett Chris
Fields karl Friston raphael Kaufman
anatoly Levinchuk Roslyn Moran Elba
Serrano carol Van Hoof Tim Verbelen Swan
Webb and Michael Zargum So, big
appreciations to all of those who served
in the Scientific Advisory Board this
year, and Beren actively soliciting self
and aloe nominations for the Scientific
Advisory Board in 2023 and just
connect to us via email if you're
interested and we can provide you the
forms. And now we can more clearly
delineate the formal roles of the board
of directors, which are to implement
institute scale, formal strategy and
governance, specification and oversight
of officers, and to apply active
inference at the organizational scale
from the insight and guidance based work
of the Scientific Advisory Board and
their roles and functions include the
stewardship of organizational units,
education and research, assisting with
project development at different stages,
periodic meetings as a scientific
Advisory board quarterly as well as
subset meetings with a special interest,
focus and other areas of insight and
engagement. Any comments?
All right,
another helpful view is that of the
chains of creation of the Institute. So
these edges reflect defined types of
relationships that are not merely part
whole or compositional, but enabling or
Constructor. Heins and the Institute is
on the far left here, which enables and
creates organizational unit niches the
educational and research organizational
units that ensemble and facilitate
projects which then have attention on
project specific system of interest and
their accompanying foraging products and
so on. Anyone want to add any comments
on this systems engineering diagram as
it relates to the Institute?
So, yeah, basically this schema is
helping us to manage attention on
specific works of someone is doing.
And I believe next
year we will bring more systems concepts
in place in different types of modeling
and modeling force definitions of
these different parts of encoding chain.
And so we will have opportunity in case
we have some developments in terms of
number of participants. We can
manage all organizational work with
support of such attention management
system, let's say.
All right, carrying on,
we're continuing to work and revise on
the logo and brand redesign for the
Institute. So for now we'll just leave
it as a gray box, but there's some
really exciting and artistic designs
that we're working with and we're
looking forward to sharing more about
those designs and the designer when the
time is right in the beginning of the
year. Okay, on to talking
about different modalities of
participation. So what previously was
referenced by just saying come
participate in the Institute is now more
clearly annotated as a volunteer
program. So of course everyone is always
welcome to engage with synchrony active
coherence Institute materials like live
streams and publications and everyone is
welcome to join synchronous drop in
meetings and the discord. The volunteer
program keeps you in the loop about
specific affordances for contribution
and facilitates your participation
across projects and learning groups. So
a volunteer is somebody who wants to
take an active step in their learning
and applying of active inference and
maybe focus in on one or more project
and also just make sure that they're in
the loop with high quality communication
about different affordances to
participate. And excitingly
that informal lane for participation
separated out from the internship
program gives us a lot of expressivity
to work with those who want to have a
more accountability and a higher
intensity engagement. So the internship
program was mentioned in the previous
roundtable and after initializing the
official internship program in October
of 2022 sorry to typo there. We have
twelve registered interns who are
currently active and several more will
be beginning in early 2023. So this was
really awesome to be meeting
and connecting with some institute
participants who have been around a long
time and who were looking to take the
next step in their work, as well as a
lot of others who came in, because this
idea of and internship, which can be
real formal recognized contribution was
very salient. So the internship consists
of several main parts. The first main
part is education and that
active education looks like joining one
or more learning group, specifically the
textbook group and the systems thinking
intensives as well as some self driven
education around reading and listening.
The second component of the internship
is the project based Learning, a
contribution to and institute project
which we're going to go through in the
coming slides. And there's a mentorship
and inclination component such that the
interns and the institute's visions and
goals and preferences are all aligned in
their inaction. So this is a great
program that we look forward to really
bolstering and carrying forward year
after year. Any comments on these
points.
All right. And so just to close out the
institute level section, we've continued
to grow across our social media
platforms and look forward to anyone who
wants to contribute to help develop
these platforms as well onto
the education organizational unit.
Active one of the keystone educational
aspects of our year for many of us was
the active inference textbook group.
The active inference textbook of Par,
Pazulo and Friston was released as an
open source textbook at the end of March
2022 and we were ready to
spin up the first cohort of the textbook
group in May 2022.
And now about
six months later, the first cohort has
completed their study of the text and
they are invited to serve in a learning
assistant role for future cohorts.
In about September through December,
we had the second cohort begin the first
half of the textbook. And so in January
2023, cohort two is going to complexity
chapters six through ten and the third
cohort is going to begin. What we do
in the textbook group is continual
deployment of value added services and
scaffolding of a shared epistemic niche.
Of course, if somebody wants to read and
work on the textbook alone, they're
welcome to. And we also hope to
cultivate a space in the textbook groups
that's engaging and allows people to
increase their familiarity and fluency
and rigor of understanding of active
inference through using questions
and developing discourse through using
the active. Inference ontology and
weaving the ontology through their
thinking and also to develop their
mathematical bases, whether that's
thinking about the fundamentals of
statistics and linear algebra and
Bayesian theorem, or whether people are
interested in a more advanced work like
connecting the dots between different
formalisms. So it was an awesome year.
We had probably 50 around
there participants who were active in
different ways and who also got
activated into some other projects. So
we just encourage you whether you're
listening to this early enough to join
Cohort Three in January 2023 or whether
you're listening later, we'll still be
offering this and other textbook groups.
So if you want to learn and learn well
together, then the textbook group is
going to be a unique and special
opportunity. Anything that people want
to add.
All right, let me add something.
It was very nice how it
was rolled from Ontology for using
for these value added services.
So the work that was done with ontology
and I think it's mostly because of the
tool, the code, but anyway,
force augmenting this work
with the textbook in a group and having
such affordances in terms of meta data
or quick access for some additional
information, it really brings more
value. For educational process, visit
textbook, make it generative.
Agreed, there can be a lot to look at
and go through, which is only what we
should expect. But the structure of the
learning environment, asynchronously and
synchronously is simply not possible
to offer or derive alone. So again,
we hope it's something like a center of
gravity for people who want to be
proactive and in this type of scientific
and educational space, really catalyze
their learning onto the
live streams and the educational
function of them. In the fourth quarter
of 2022, we had just and amazing set
of guests and focal paper discussions.
We had guests in the math stream related
to category theory, in the organization
stream relating to strategy and
governance in the model streams related
to branching time, active coherence and
the Pi MDP package, and guests in
the guest streams related to radical and
activism, math, artificial intelligence
and biological intelligence. And we
featured three papers in the
discussions around the paper streams and
that was a worked example of the
Bayesian mechanics of classical objects
in Livestream 49, exteroception as
modeling allostasis as control in
Livestream 50 and Canonical Neural
Networks Perform Active inference in 51.
And each of these series were
exceptional. The authors joined and we
had a Dot Zero Zero crew each time who
was really committed to understanding
and communicating the material. So there
are many ways you can help us co create
special and engaging live streams in
2023. You are always welcome to
participate in preparing and enacting
live streams. Whether you do or don't
want to actually join a live stream,
it's also great to self nominate or
suggest or introduce somebody to join
Forestream. It's also a great
opportunity to collaborate on a Dot Zero
Zero background and context video.
That's a great way to have your studying
leveraged and amplified by thousands of
fold. Your notes will not just live on
your own computer, they'll exist in a
space where others can benefit from
them. And feel free to just join those
regular Livestream meetings to learn
more. Any more comments?
One ongoing series that is capturing the
last few slots and is ongoing
is the governing Continuous
Transformation Bookstream Bleu. Want to
add any words on that? Sure.
So I think I was inspired by the
transformation of the lab to the
Institute and by joining the board of
Directors to study governance in a more
formal way. So we have this
book that is a recent text that reframes
governance in the light active coherence
lab. So we undertook study.
Tyler Sullenberg and myself and Daniel
have been participating in the Dot zero
versions of the bookstream and we're
doing one video per chapter of the text
and we will get together for some
discussions at the end of each book
section. So if you ant to participate
either in joining the Dot zero or in a
discussion of the material presented in
the text, get in touch because we would
love to have other perspectives and
additional feedback. Thanks.
Well, as alluded to earlier by Dave,
these live streams are not just a dead
end. At the Active Inference Journal we
pick up where the live stream ends and
our goal is to increase the
accessibility and index ability of live
streams and audio visual material.
So to give a summary of just an
instance, like a case of the journal,
we took the transcript of guest stream
16 with Mark Solmes on consciousness as
precision optimization. Here's a
screenshot with Mark, myself, Esteves
and Dave having those live streams and
then through the development of a
journal, utilities, GitHub repo and a
tremendous amount of scripts and
expertise from Dave. The outcome with
some automated and some manual
components is an augmented transcript
that contains different features.
It can be as plain as what comes off of
the transcription artificial
intelligence, it can be as rich as
hyperlinked and interactive with
embedded images, translations and so
on. And as of today,
December 14, we have Dois for
all of the paper live streams that
occurred during 2022 and
now we're working through the backlog of
previous streams. And so what that looks
like on the live stream Coda page is
you'll find the event name, the date it
was live streamed, the video watch link,
the title and link to the paper and
information on the guests. You'll also
find that there are a link to the
slides, a link to the transcript,
a DOI provided if you want to cite it,
and also a link to the GitHub where that
series can be versioned so people can
fix typos in a decentralized way that's
incremented and trackable. They can also
add simulations and all kinds of other
contributions that people might want to
do so that the thread of these
discussions stays alive. Dave, it was
great work and a fun time this year.
What would you like to add or provide?
Well, we're just getting
going in a few very
technical and very high impact Fields,
notably biology and public
health. There has been a huge push
internationally across disciplines to
get word level, phrase level,
conceptual, graph level, access to all
researchers. It's a lot of material,
but it is a small fraction of all of the
scholarly activity. I think even in that
field, the presentation,
the reuse of spoken material is
still pretty minor. And between
the various text repositories, the
different open science initiatives and
active inference Institute, I think just
continuing to push to make particularly
interdisciplinary and transdisciplinary
ongoing realtime scholarship, the norm
over the next few years will
really pay off tremendously. There's a
lot of legal battles that are going to
be getting worse. Folks that want to
take possession, take ownership of the
entire genome of every organism and
charge you to know anything.
In my opinion,
criminally evil activity is being run
through legal systems and common
law. One hope that simply overwhelming
this with virtuous activity is going to
help to make that much less of
a pathology that's afflicting the
species and other species.
Wow. From transcription
to the metacrisis and back.
It's really been educational though and
we all know just in the unrecorded
private conversations we have and in the
seminars and in the meetings that we've
had over the previous years enabled by
video conversation, amazing things are
said and amazing perspectives are shared
by experts, beginners, all kinds of
experts and people with their own lived
experience. And yet the best we can do
in many situations is link to a video
and sometimes not even that. So to have
all of the transcripts and an increasing
number of captions and their
translations in a searchable and
trainable and accessible form is
again, as Dave mentioned, we hope that
this can become a continuous development
leaving a huge amount of functional
products in the niche and the costs are
not high and it is more possible than
ever. Truly. Within the last several
months there were developments in speech
and text processing that changed our
ways of working. So that was just quite
exciting to have set out on this path
years ago and see so much of it evolve
in the last few months. Alex or anyone
else?
Yeah, it's actually a
transformational project for Institute
because it's in the beginning of the
year. It was like a dream to have all
videos in transcripts.
And this project,
I believe, heavily technology driving
with Dave's expertise, give us these
pictures when we actually have
transcripts and have backlog when we can
improve and having this text corpus.
As and Institute we are on frontier in
terms of using tools that we have
from AI developments and all of these
text force concept will
be developed in different ways with all
different kinds of new technologies.
Awesome. All right,
carrying on. Yvonne, want to describe
the work in the systems engineering
intensive? Yes,
sure. So next year we
start new intensive for four weeks
for beginning and this type of intensive
will mostly for our
internals, but we are
open to welcoming all
others who are interested in systems
engineering approach.
We will go through
the concepts and mostly on
role concepts like they are
the cornerstone in the systems
engineering, it's very helpful to
negotiating within the projects.
So besides
all of the theory Parr, we have
practical parts, and we also
have some cases like you can see here
with the concepts and examples
from the real life. It will
help to understand the
systems engineering approach more
precisely.
Awesome. So it's going to be four weeks
synchronous with also asynchronous work
and learning. I want to add a few more
details. Here.
We'Ll provide the RSVP form for
your conversation, and here
we provide some specific DAGs. And if
you are available for specific dates,
and if you have Jorge questions,
you can easily reach us out via
email.
Awesome. This like active inference.
It's a framework that helps us think,
shapes, and scaffolds our attention and
affordance, and also marries well
with active inference as we continue to
think about the Institute and all of its
attendant systems as something like a
synthesis of active inference with
systems engineering. Want to summarize
this slide? Yeah, just one thought
for free.
This time we will provide the
linkage between active and force
instance system thinking, and we can
publish some
small review on what the
entire linkage is now and
how we consider it now.
Yes, this type
of activity is part of the
educational program of Institute for
Augmented Intelligence. And you
can see here the link of the Institute
and Parr of the courses that are
available in English. It's partly
translated by anonymous translation,
so it could be somehow not so
play in English. But anyway, it's very
useful content to moving
any projects forward to
their purposes, whatever research
projects is or industrial or
whatever projects you
are launching.
Excellent. All right. Any final concepts
on education?
It's been quite an educational year.
Those who are in the game and listened
to some conversations, joined a few,
read some papers, scanned the social
medias, stayed abreast of what was
happening and changing in our field. It
was incredible, actually. When people
look back on 2022 and plus or minus
several years from now, there's so much
happening and so much to learn that
those who choose to act first and step
into the fray are already learning,
at least for myself, more than we
thought was possible onto the
research projects. So here we're just
going to more cursorily overview some
research projects because they're all in
progress with a lot of different
outcomes, and just join the meetings for
these projects when we pick back up in
2023. So in the Active
Inference ontology, we are continuing to
develop the ontology, fleshing out the
terms list as well as associated
definitions, examples, counter examples,
and so on, as well as the translations
into different languages and with the
mathematics. This is what facilitates an
engineering grade approach to the active
inference knowledge ecosystem.
In the Active blockfronts project,
primarily with the development work of
Yakup, we've continued to explore
computational implementations of active
inference, primarily in Python and
Pymdp. But also in a few other ways and
this will be a continued active
locus in 2023. We had a paper
and a poster and maybe some other
outcomes from this project in 2022 and
we're going to make it even more this
year. In robotics and embodied we
have JF facilitating a really unique
project and dimension. It's been great
to have JF's experience with the
physical and the metaphysical, one might
say, and the way that they come together
in these society of Lego
entities. But also a great project and
offering where those who want to learn
more about symbolic active inference and
robotics can connect with JF and
work on this really unique project. And
then there's a few other project seeds
that we're looking to activate as
needed, which is the graphical interface
project asking what is it like
to learn and apply active inference from
a visual and intermodal perspective
highlighting accessibility and rigor.
And in the Cognitive Agent Modeling
Project, where we're doing research,
analysis to understand the similarities
and differences amongst different
cognitive modeling frameworks, such as
active inference and others. So that in
the future, when we say, well, we study
attention this way, we can also flesh
that out by saying and these other
common frameworks that are used in field
one, two, three, study attention this
way, and this framework doesn't use
attention. And so this is why we think
that active inference could do better
than this framework in this place and
help this framework in this way. And
then we have the individual research
projects which just reflect the research
projects that driven individuals are the
champions of and they're
not always going to be carried out using
the onFt ontologies narratives, formal
documents and tools of the institute.
Which is to say, it's not necessarily DA
Costa document owned by the active
inference institute with an open source
dedication, but it could be. And these
research projects have been very
fruitful and engaging and it's been an
Conor to connect with so many diverse
individuals who are making it happen in
their own way and sometimes working
amidst the traditional research
structures. But needing an outlet.
That's not what they have. And other
times coming from outside of traditional
research structures. And that's just
really special to see at the institute.
Just to give a little one more detail
on active block force instance with some
memes and roadmaps. Our gain conceptual
focus this year was understanding the
multi agent case, active coherence lab
simulations, understanding the
dimensionality and some of the
constraints and processes associated
with multiagent simulations will then
let us revisit exafferent POMDP,
partially observable Markov decision
process modeling schemes and heuristics
and we think of active block, for
instance, having two primary
departments. On the theoretical side,
there's a host of questions related to
different functionalities of models and
computational implementations as well as
exciting areas like quantum active
inference. And on the applied side there
are various settings and use cases where
we can really start to make that last
mile between a general purpose package
and a domain specific use case.
Any final comments on research?
All right, well,
there are so many ways to talk about
what comes next. And I'm hoping that in
early 2023 we'll be communicating those
to all of you. Here's just one synthesis
visualization to help those who might
want to see we are niche bound
on all sides, and we wouldn't want it
any other way. At the Institute scale,
we have a renewed understanding and
structural enablements with the board of
directors in a formal governance role
and the Scientific Advisory Board as a
broader Global cohort of individuals
who want to be scientific informal
advisors. And we're continuing to
develop our grants and partnership
programs as well as make advancements
on the bolts domains business,
operational, legal, technical and
social. Within the institute,
we have two organizational units the
active educational unit and the research
unit. At the Research and Education Unit
level, we're interested to have
stewarded development by those who have
that kind of vision and capacity to
share and generally to increase
participation, quality and quantity and
increase our capacity to model projects.
For example, in 2022, we were able to
develop an improved metamodel or a
template for live streams which enabled
us to increase the quantity and quality
of the live streams. And we look forward
to doing those kinds of metamodeling
approaches across other working product
and system of interest types. And the
last mile where the work is actually
done, where the epistemic rubber hits
the Pragmatic road, is in the projects,
where we hope and expect Arnold Pfeffer
to see sustained participation from
Global participants, volunteers and
interns. And it's through the projects
and the services that they project back.
Hinton the niche by which we actually
close the loop through continual active
inference and service. So here's the
live streams going out through a data
channel. Here's the transcripts leaking
out of a GitHub repo. Here's somebody
translating the biology into a new
language so that all the previous
projects can be empowered. Here's a
script coming out. Here's some other
ambassadorship. And so this is just one
way. We are representing to you
and to ourselves what the Institute is
and what it does in a complex and
changing niche. Any multi
level thoughts that you fellows would
like to share?
Last two ones, like thinking assistance.
Okay. 2022 was a year
of artificial intelligence
generated images and text for many.
So thought we'd throw out a few computer
generated, not designer generated
logos, but they're pretty cool. We made
many more and had fun times, I think all
of us dialoguing. And next year in
the active diffusion project. We'll have
a lot more to say about this.
Well, what would a good understanding
enable of the Institute and our niche?
What are some unique predictions and
implications of our work? What are the
next steps for free energy principle.
And active inference and the Institute.
What are the goals of this research or
work? And what are you still curious
about? A closing round from everyone.
As we have our final Livestream
of the year.
I want to know more about this active
diffusion project and where can I sign
up? Sounds way fun. That's my
closing thought. Catechism incoming.
So it's like closing roundtable
for this year, I believe. I can say that
it was quite a journey and we
redefining a lot of stuff in terms of
our own understanding about
understanding of niche and adaptive,
our structure to be able to
be more and more valuable
for different communities, for different
possible intersonse stakeholders.
Force. Next year's lips look bright.
Thank you, Yvonne and Dave.
Yeah. For me, the most encoding thing
is our internship, and I'm really
looking forward to how people from
different domain will learn
more about active coherence and bring
their perspective, Hinton this area
and get it back our
perspective. This is
really awesome, I think.
Thank you, Dave. That's extraordinary,
the range of interests and expertise
that have come through some folks.
You see their faces every week. Some
folks are working hard, but behind the
scenes there have been folks that
dropped in a lot a year or
two ago we haven't seen for a while. I
suspect they are greatly enriched and by
this collaboration and that some of them
will come back. And whether we see them
or not, they're using what they've
learned, both the soft and the hard
skills in enriching other areas.
Wow. Totally agree with all of that. I
may have to sneak in a final separate
stream to review one slide per
guest stream or paper because we truly
had such a range of guests.
And for those who tune
in asynchronously or those who
join the meetings,
it's been incredible. The bravery and
the honesty and the authenticity
that learners and researchers all around
the world brought to this little corner
of the Internet in its truly earliest
days will always be remembered.
Okay, till next time.
Thank you.